next question is from Colleen what
product would you refuse to promote or
advertise I'm going to expand this the
product or service we've talked about
the what distinguishes our show from
corporate media before and we've talked
about our relationship to advertisers
and that entire thing I won't we do that
there are many products that I've
already refused to promote or advertised
as well as services as far as services
check cashing and pawn shop type places
payday loans etc I just wouldn't do it
these are businesses that are sort of
operating on the fringes of legality and
are drastically taking advantage of a
poor people of lower middle income
people the bail bonds industry is
another one I would just not promote any
of those businesses on the show period
now as far as products we've turned down
a lot of advertisers some of them are
they tend to be sort of in the
pseudoscience energy products and
so-called health supplements with
completely unproven health benefits
alleged on the products healthy energy
bites I got were the number one
ingredient with sugar that how could I
possibly tell my audience that this is
even remotely healthy never mind is
going to provide a brain boost or energy
or whatever the hell it was that it
supposedly provided I and I can think of
a lot of other stuff maybe we wouldn't
do at we had a chemical company which
wanted to advertise on the show at one
point I turned that down I wouldn't do a
fossil fuel company there's really a
very long list actually I mean there are
shows where it just seems like they're
having the audience prepare for the
apocalypse the entirety of the show and
it seems just like it's a documentary or
not a documentary but an advertisement
throughout the entire thing and
commercial yeah what I was looking for
so I mean we have Jim Bakker and it's
bonus buckets I mean those are classic
we're not going to be advertising those
on the show anytime soon if people are
looking at the image that's over my
shoulder this is a still image from this
is actually supposedly like a religious
TV show but as Pat alluded to it does
appear to be just an infomercial
offering the new bulk sampler bundle
which contains nearly 24,000 servings of
something we
I guess would last you I don't know you
do the math I don't know how long years
right I don't even know what the product
did I don't know if this is dehydrated
mashed potatoes or oats or whatever oh
yeah they say about 20 years so I mean
if there's an apocalypse that happens
even though you may be in your 80s while
you're watching this you're good for the
next 20 years you're good for the next
which I guess is a nice nice to know
yeah I wouldn't do the apocalyptic type
products the way that Glenn Beck was
doing at one point I would be dubious
about doing certain mobile apps if I see
the app as sort of now there's before it
used to be much more clear when you had
malware straight-up malware or malicious
programs versus non now where the line
is kind of blurry now because you do
have apps that have some sort of
official functionality but really the
main point of the app is to collect
information and then sell it and sell
you products and whatever and sometimes
we get approached by apps that seem
pretty sketchy to me and I've opted out
of those I think there's probably more
products that would never even come to
us because it's so obvious that we would
never advertise what it is that they're
selling on the program I mean has there
ever been a in a product or something
where you thought they had a good name
behind the brand and you start
advertising for them and then it turns
out there's some big media controversy
around the corner and you just didn't
foresee that and you have to kind of
backtrack away from them I don't think
so there have been times where I was
approached by a company that I genuinely
thought was a reputable company and then
I did more research and found endless
allegations about being scammed by the
company online but it wasn't so much
that there was like a huge public
incident a shock event for lack of a
better term I like using that term no it
hasn't exactly happened that way but
I've uncovered some pretty horrible
stuff when researching advertisers in
the past